In the lead-up to the 2020 Academy Awards,
set to air on Sunday, February 9, Adam Sandler
was near the head of the pack for Best Actor
contenders.
For his performance as Diamond District jeweler
and self-destructive gambling addict Howard
Ratner in the Safdie brothers' crime thriller
Uncut Gems, Sandler had most everyone believing
he'd land at least a nomination for the coveted
award.
"That's the dumbest f---ing bet I ever heard."
However, when the list of 2020 Oscar nominations
rolled out, Sandler's name was nowhere to
be found, despite the fact that viewers everywhere
thought he'd be a shoo-in.
Now, The New York Post has run quotes from
an anonymous Academy member who commented
on some of the actors who didn't score Oscar
nominations this year: Dolemite Is My Name
star Eddie Murphy, Hustlers lead Jennifer
Lopez, The Farewell actress Awkwafina, and,
of course, Sandler.
The nameless actor revealed the real reason
why Adam Sandler was snubbed, and the answer
isn't pretty.
Let's not forget: Adam Sandler is a seriously
funny actor.
"Stay here.
Stay as long as you can.
For the love of God, cherish it!"
He's split sides in films like Happy Gilmore,
Billy Madison, The Waterboy, The Wedding Singer,
Big Daddy, and more, gaining fame as much
more than a former Saturday Night Live player.
In the 2000s, Sandler ventured into more dramatic
territory with Spanglish, Punch-Drunk Love,
and Funny People, effectively proving he wasn't
a one-trick pony.
But at a certain point, Sandler's track record
grew spotty when he began signing on to films
that were, well…less-than-spectacular.
He racked up Razzies, basically the ugly step-sister
to the merit-based award ceremonies, for Just
Go With It and Jack and Jill, two of Sandler's
worst movies ever, and tarnished his reputation
in the process.
It's only been in recent years, through his
turns in films like Netflix's The Meyerowitz
Stories and now Uncut Gems, that Sandler has
begun to shed his "King of Bad Movies" moniker.
Sadly, Oscars voters have a stronger memory
than the general public does.
The reason why he didn't receive an Oscar
nomination, according to the well-known character
actor and member of the Academy, is because
people don't associate the name "Adam Sandler"
with accolades as prestigious as Academy Awards.
The source claimed:
"There are a lot of movies, a lot of performances
per year for us to watch.
Unfortunately, actors become brands.
Sandler's brand doesn't scream 'Oscar.'"
Ouch.
During an appearance on The Howard Stern Show
in early December 2019, Sandler threatened
revenge on the movie-going masses if he didn't
nab an Academy Award for his performance in
Uncut Gems.
The actor warned that he would take a role
in an unbelievably bad movie to make everyone
regret not nominating him for, and, more importantly,
awarding him with, an Oscar.
Sandler said:
"If I don't get it, I'm going to f---ing come
back and do one again that is so bad on purpose
just to make you all pay.
That's how I get them."
He added that though it would be a, quote,
"funny big thing" for him to receive an Oscar
nomination, he would be "there to win" if
it actually happened.
We all know that it didn't, and it seems Sandler's
plan for payback could still be intact.
Given that his filmography isn't exactly packed
wall to wall with winners, the actor doesn't
have much to lose if he does go through with
making a terrible film, except the respect
of the Academy voting body.
In response to Sandler's comments on The Howard
Stern Show, one member allegedly complained
that the actor has an "arrogance" to him,
and that his threat showed, quote, "a lack
of respect."
For everyone's sake, hopefully Sandler sticks
to more substantial gigs and doesn't actually
make a total stinker to follow up Uncut Gems.
He may not have been placed in the running
for Oscars gold following his turn in the
film, but the fact that he generated genuine
buzz for a Best Actor award speaks volumes.
May Sandler's future, and ours, feature more
roles like Howard Ratner and fewer like…well…
"I feel like Julia Roberts in that movie!"
"Pretty Woman?"
"No, the one where she's a hooker!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.